what's in the water good evening to you
thank you for sticking with us at 6
30. i'm brian loftis and i'm denise
valdez health officials say
real water made people sick and right
now we're learning more about what's
exactly in it
and it's a story our i-team has been
working on for months and one you may
have seen on cbs this morning
the i-team's david charns here now with
new information coming from a plant
worker
david denise the i-team has told you
there are at least 11 cases
of acute non-viral hepatitis linked to
this real water that's the name of the
company
with 50 more under investigation right
now and lawyers suing the company say
their main focus
is on how this water was made real water
was making its alkaline water in
henderson they claimed it had
added health benefits due to its
chemical makeup just last month lawyers
interviewed casey aiken a former real
water employee
in this video obtained by cbs news aiken
who told lawyers he was in charge of
mixing a concentrate
into this water said he received a low
reading on a meter
used in that process and that's when he
told lawyers he had asked a manager what
to do
and he added more he told you to add
more concentrate correct
but he didn't tell you how much no he
didn't tell me how much you do
understand that if you potentially
add more concentrate than
you usually use that there could
potentially be a problem with water
i wouldn't think so you would think so
no i wouldn't okay but you don't know
what's in the concentrate
if i'm putting it into somebody that's
ingesting it i would think that it's
safe no matter what
that's my thought now attorneys say
their focus is on batches of water that
was made last fall
we believe that there's something in
that process that
was off and was causing you know
these extra unsafe levels of toxins to
get into the water
the majority of our clients they all got
sick
with these liver injuries in the same
time period now those clients include
several children who according to
lawyers had to go to salt lake city
for treatment and that's actually when a
doctor there
suspected there was a link now the fda
has recommended all home delivery
customers stop
drinking this water it also did come in
bottles that were sold in stores and the
fda ordered stores to stop
selling it the lawyers do tell the
i-team those batches
came from a plant in arizona and not the
one in henderson where those lawyers say
the man who you just heard from worked
now in a video statement posted back in
march real waters majority owner and
founder apologized to customers
the company has not released any sort of
comment since
i'm david charns 8 news now